what's wrong martin having trouble
choosing
yeah i just can't decide which tool i
want to use
i don't know if this new hammer will do
everything i need
and i don't want to throw away my old
mallet without being sure
well what if i told you that you didn't
have to choose right now and you can use
both
that sounds great stay tuned if you want
to know more
this works for storcraft as a site
reliability engineer where she is on
call maintaining their custom storefront
store craft systems are developed
in-house in python and have been running
on virtual machines for years
a setup which evolved as storcraft's
businesses did
these virtual machines use slightly
different versions of python
this is causing extra pain and work for
liz and her team
this is looking for a way to reduce this
pain by updating
all the components to current python and
also migrating away from virtual
machines onto something more scalable
like serverless
liz knows that this upgrade will take
time and her team needs to make sure
the existing system keeps running she
realizes that she can best achieve this
by completing the upgrade in two steps
first moving to serverless then making
the language upgrades
starcraft is about to launch a new
recommendation engine which is written
using python 3.9
liz sees this as the perfect candidate
to deploy a serverless first
skipping the virtual machine altogether
looking at the options available on
google cloud
liz sees that while she could deploy on
cloud functions
she would be forced to use only specific
versions of python
however she sees that the newest
serverless offering from google cloud
cloud run doesn't have this limitation
so she chooses to deploy there
instead creating this service on cloud
run
liz has complete control over the
container making use of the official
python images
on docker hub she can pick the exact
version of python she needs down to the
patch level
by specifying the base image in the from
line of her dockerfile
as each cloud run service is based on
its own container image
which are each defined by their own
dockerfile liz has complete control over
the languages used in each part of her
setup
since each cloudrun service has this
level of isolation
liz can move each of them to cloud run
one
at a time she's also able to maintain
the services running on the original
virtual machines
until the team has the availability to
upgrade
however during the refactor of the
account services component storcraft's
development team finds that it has a
dependency on the sweet ldap package
which doesn't yet support python 3. liz
is able to keep the service
running on the now deprecated python 2.7
by specifying the latest version of
python27 in the dockerfile
as soon as a suite ldap package has
python 3 support
liz can test this new version by
gradually rolling out
a new revision of the service using the
traffic splitting feature of cloudrun
she can set the new revision of account
service to say
service only five percent of visitors
that way only some of her customers end
up using the new code
if she notices that something isn't
working as intended she can easily roll
back to the old version
by migrating each service in turn liz is
able to control them
in isolation allowing for more
incremental
upgrade process and a more reliable
environment
but martin i will have to take away that
mallet at some point
ah okay then
you still can have your hammer well i do
like this new hammer that now that i'm
used to it
great great